Black Widow yeah so how excited are you
for this I'm pretty excited
joining the MCU yeah but and not just
trying to get like like joining with a
great project like hate shortland
this unbelievable director you know the
Russian agent Black Widow
Florence Pugh Rachel Weisz I mean it
seems like a dream come true
is it have you actually read a script or
is it one of these types of things where
you sign like sight unseen because it's
the MCU exactly I was told the story I
was told the story that I was told what
I would be doing in the story and it's
very satisfying and very cool and I was
kind of like you know I don't need to
see a script I trust you guys we're not
going to show either it's not your
choice and I was like okay where do I
sign
right exactly when you start filming cuz
I heard it too soon or July yeah I think
it's early June yeah exactly I my last
thing for you by the way can't wait and
congratulations
what do you stranger things season 3
premieres I believe on the 4th of July
right yeah how does it work because
obviously you're going to do season 4 I
heard it's four or five seasons the
whole thing well who knows what happens
with your character but say you were
going back how does it work is you're
like the rest of the year booked yeah do
you know what I mean yeah I mean it gets
it gets pretty you know with these
longer contracts and stuff it gets
pretty
pretty weird in terms of like scheduling
and jostling and all that stuff because
I would imagine like they have to be
getting ready to gear up like later this
year to film so I'm like wondering so
it's like Black Widow right into
something else but let's talk into
season three what are you excited for
fans to see how do you think a chick is
it bigger is it more of what can you
tease it's bigger I mean it's bigger
it's and it's sort of more Spielberg Ian
like I felt like season 1 was very
Stephen King season 2 was very Spielberg
and then we got even more Spielberg Ian
and our our aesthetic it's also like
it's got a lot of color to it this year
like we really get into the eighties
it's it's 85 mic hoppers got a whole new
getup he's got a mustache like we're
leaning into it they're really fun
interesting way and also you know it's
got a lot of love in it it always has
from the very beginning I think that's
the dignitary special about the show is
it
tremendous heart like I always get
choked up when I watch it and this
season is like no different like it
takes a lot of risks but in its essence
it's gonna like smack you
like in the heart and it's really fun
and it's really beautiful and there's
some big big surprises so
I cannot wait